This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the middle of the 20th century, the influential psychoanalyst Eric Erickson came up with a set of theories about human development. In the earliest stage of life, he said, babies need to gain a sense of trust in their caregivers. To bring this about, the psychoanalyst recommended that parents shower their children with affection and quickly respond to signals of distress. These concepts were to become influential in the field later known as developmental psychology. In 1944, Eric Erickson's ideas were put to the test in his own life. His wife Joan Erickson gave birth to their fourth child, Neil. The labor
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。20世纪中叶，颇具影响力的心理分析学家埃里克·埃里克森提出了一套关于人类发展的理论。他说，在生命的最初阶段，婴儿需要对照顾者建立起信任感。为了实现这一点，这位心理分析学家建议父母给予孩子充分的关爱，并对他们的痛苦信号做出迅速反应。这些概念后来在发展心理学领域产生了深远影响。1944年，埃里克·埃里克森的这些理念在他自己的生活中受到了考验。他的妻子琼·埃里克森生下了他们的第四个孩子尼尔。分娩
proved difficult and Joan was sedated after the birth. Meanwhile, doctors pulled Erick aside to give him some bad news about his newborn son. The doctors said that baby Neil suffered from what they called Mongolism or Mongolian idiocy, what is today known as Down syndrome. Neil was going to be developmentally challenged and would likely die within a short period of time. Rather than burden the parents with the care of such a difficult baby, the doctors recommended that Neil be immediately sent away to an institution. The doctors recommended that Neil be immediately sent away to an institution. Tormented by the decision before him, Eric Erickson did what a lot of us might do in his situation.
过程十分艰难，琼在产后被注射了镇静剂。与此同时，医生把埃里克叫到一旁，告诉了他关于他刚出生的儿子的坏消息。医生说，小尼尔患有所谓的“蒙古症”或“蒙古痴呆症”，也就是今天所说的唐氏综合征。尼尔的发育将会有障碍，而且很可能在短时间内夭折。医生建议不要让父母背负照顾这样一个“困难”婴儿的负担，应立即将尼尔送往收容机构。医生建议立即将尼尔送往收容机构。面对这一决定，埃里克·埃里克森备受煎熬，他做了许多人在这种情况下可能会做的事。
He phoned a friend. But in his case, the friend happened to be one of the most famous anthropologists of all time. A scholar who had challenged the idea that our biology makes us who we are. Very much like Eric Erickson himself, Margaret Mead believed in the power of nurture. She believed that we are less the product
他给一位朋友打了电话。但在他的案例中，这位朋友恰好是有史以来最著名的社会人类学家之一。这位学者曾挑战过“生物学决定论”的观点。和埃里克·埃里克森本人非常相似，玛格丽特·米德相信后天培养的力量。她认为，我们与其说是
of our cells and genetic codes, and more the creation of our families, cultures, and societies. our families, cultures, and societies. This week on Hidden Brain, the surprising advice Margaret Mead gave Eric Erickson, and how we draw distinctions between differences and deficiencies. From its inception, the field of anthropology had a problem. Western scholars in the 19th century, writing the code tales of colonial conquest, traveled to the ends of the earth to publish ethnographies of diverse peoples. Using the vocabulary of the emerging field of evolutionary science, anthropologists created taxonomies of people, like Darwin had done with his species.
细胞和基因代码的产物，不如说是家庭、文化和社会塑造的产物。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨玛格丽特·米德给埃里克·埃里克森的惊人建议，以及我们如何区分“差异”与“缺陷”。人类学领域自诞生之初就存在一个问题。19世纪的西方学者在撰写殖民征服的史诗时，远赴世界各地，发表关于不同民族的民族志。他们利用新兴进化科学的词汇，像达尔文对物种分类那样，对人类进行了分类。
Such a comparison of people involved drawing lines between them and posing questions like, how is this group different from another? Which one is stronger or smarter? Almost invariably, these lines involved racial classifications. Almost invariably, these lines involved racial classifications. The anthropologists concluded that groups outside of the West were more primitive, less evolved versions of humanity, that they were less smart, less able. The early biological anthropologist Samuel Morton ranked intelligence by measuring the size of human skulls. White people had the largest skulls and thus the greatest mental capacity, while Native
这种对人的比较涉及在他们之间划定界限，并提出诸如“这个群体与另一个群体有何不同？”“哪一个更强或更聪明？”之类的问题。这些界限几乎总是涉及种族分类。这些界限几乎总是涉及种族分类。人类学家得出结论，西方以外的群体是更原始、进化程度更低的人类版本，他们更不聪明，能力更差。早期的生物人类学家塞缪尔·莫顿通过测量人类头骨的大小来对智力进行排名。白人的头骨最大，因此智力最高，而原住民
peoples and African Americans lagged far behind. These theories about fixed traits and stark differences between groups dovetailed with the eugenics movement. Since biology makes us who we are, shouldn't biology determine who should marry whom, who should and shouldn't be having children, and which babies were worth saving? A counter-revolution to these ideas erupted in the 20th century. A new wave of scholars challenged the notion that some groups were biologically
和非裔美国人则远远落后。这些关于固定特征和群体间巨大差异的理论与优生学运动不谋而合。既然生物学决定了我们是谁，那么生物学难道不应该决定谁该与谁结婚、谁该或不该生孩子，以及哪些婴儿值得拯救吗？20世纪，一场针对这些思想的反革命运动爆发了。新一代学者挑战了某些群体在生物学上
superior to others. Leading this charge was a Pennsylvania-born anthropologist named Margaret Mead. Margaret Mead, I mean, she probably is the most well-known anthropologist that has ever lived. She was an iconic figure in the 20th century. Tom Pearson is an anthropologist at the University of Wisconsin-Stout and author of a book about Margaret Mead. She kind of became quite publicly well known early on in her career based on her research in Samoa in the 1920s, 1930s, which was focused on the sexual lives of young girls. In her field work, Margaret was focused on the sexual lives of young girls.
优于其他群体的观点。领导这场运动的是一位出生于宾夕法尼亚州的人类学家，名叫玛格丽特·米德。玛格丽特·米德，我想，她可能是史上最著名的人类学家。她是20世纪的标志性人物。汤姆·皮尔逊是威斯康星大学斯托特分校的人类学家，也是一本关于玛格丽特·米德的书的作者。她在职业生涯早期就因20世纪20年代和30年代在萨摩亚的研究而广为人知，该研究聚焦于年轻女孩的性生活。在田野调查中，玛格丽特专注于年轻女孩的性生活。
In her fieldwork, Margaret Mead followed the standard anthropological approach of drawing differences between people in the U.S. and people in Samoa. She described the rituals of the Samoan people, their approaches to child rearing, their sexual practices. But unlike others, Mead concluded that the differences she saw were neither innate nor shaped by biology. They were the creations of culture, upbringing, and social norms. The beliefs and practices of American adolescents were not superior to those of Samoan adolescents. They were just different. This was in the context of the early 20th century eugenics movement, where there was
在田野调查中，玛格丽特·米德遵循了标准的人类学方法，即找出美国人和萨摩亚人之间的差异。她描述了萨摩亚人的仪式、育儿方式和性习俗。但与其他学者不同的是，米德得出结论，她所看到的差异既非天生，也非由生物学决定。它们是文化、教养和社会规范的产物。美国青少年的信仰和习俗并不优于萨摩亚青少年。它们只是不同而已。这发生在20世纪初优生学运动的背景下，当时
a new era of anthropologists who were questioning a lot of the ideas that surrounded eugenics and that there are these sort of innate characteristics that differentiate groups and that determine that some people are inherently better than others. And they were proponents of a perspective that emphasized this notion of cultural relativism. That we want to try to understand different cultures on its own terms and not, you know, trying to evaluate whether one way of doing things is better or worse. And that just that this basic idea that the way people behave
出现了一批新的人类学家，他们质疑围绕优生学的许多观点，即存在某种区分群体的先天特征，并决定了某些人天生优于他人。他们是强调“文化相对主义”观点的支持者。即我们试图在不同文化的自身语境下理解它们，而不是试图评估某种做事方式是更好还是更坏。这种基本观点认为，人们的行为方式
and the way in which they come to see the world is not something that is determined by underlying biology, but is shaped by culture, something that's learned. Margaret Mead and other thinkers like her established a new branch of the field, cultural anthropology. They weighed in on the classic nature vs nurture debate and came down heavily on the side of nurture. Instead of one group being superior to another, they argued it was a mistake to rank groups
以及他们看待世界的方式，并非由潜在的生物学决定，而是由文化塑造的，是后天习得的。玛格丽特·米德和其他像她一样的思想家建立了该领域的一个新分支——文化人类学。他们参与了经典的“先天与后天”之争，并坚定地站在了“后天”这一边。他们认为，与其说一个群体优于另一个群体，不如说对群体进行排名是错误的，
as being more or less advanced. Judging others using the yardstick of one's own group as the baseline for what was good or smart said more about the judges than the people being judged. This is from an interview with Margaret Mead in 1976. We worked with the assumption of the psychic unity of mankind. What did that mean? That's a nice phrase. That meant that we were all members of the same species, and that however different the conditions under which we lived,
认为某些群体更先进或更落后是错误的。用自己群体的标准作为衡量什么是好、什么是聪明的标尺来评判他人，这反映出的更多是评判者自身的问题，而非被评判者。这段话摘自1976年对玛格丽特·米德的一次采访。我们以“人类心理统一性”为假设进行工作。那是什么意思？那是个很好的短语。这意味着我们都是同一物种的成员，无论我们生活的条件有多么不同，
whether there were people who didn't count beyond three or four, it wasn't because their capacities were less. We assumed that those differences were due to their culture. The word culture... Being different was not the same as being deficient. Always remember that you are unique, Margaret Mead advised, just like everyone else. So this was radical right in the early 20th century. And Margaret Mead, she represented this new version of anthropology. So she's this sort of like progressive, almost radical
无论是否有人数数不会超过三或四，这都不是因为他们的能力较差。我们假设这些差异是由于他们的文化造成的。文化这个词……与众不同并不等同于有缺陷。玛格丽特·米德建议道：“永远记住你是独一无二的，就像其他人一样。”所以这在20世纪初是非常激进的。玛格丽特·米德代表了这种新的人类学版本。所以她是一个进步的、近乎激进的
figure and close friends with Eric Erickson. They had formed a relationship as researchers who were both interested in how culture shapes childhood development and questions of personality and identity. And so in the 1940s when Eric Erickson and Joan Erickson, when she gives birth to their son Neil, there's some complications and she's under sedation there's some complications and she's under sedation for some procedure and the doctors tell Eric that Neil has mongolism. And in 1944, that was a term that was used to describe what we now call Down syndrome. And they had immediately recommended that Eric send Neil away. had immediately recommended that Eric send Neil away. That Neil, the infant, be separated from his mother and immediately sent to an institution.
人物，也是埃里克·埃里克森的密友。作为研究者，他们建立了深厚的关系，都对文化如何塑造儿童发展以及人格和身份认同问题感兴趣。因此，在20世纪40年代，当埃里克·埃里克森和琼·埃里克森生下儿子尼尔时，出现了一些并发症，她在接受某种手术时处于镇静状态，医生告诉埃里克，尼尔患有“蒙古症”。在1944年，这是一个用来描述我们现在所称的唐氏综合征的术语。他们立即建议埃里克把尼尔送走。他们立即建议埃里克把尼尔送走。建议将婴儿尼尔与母亲分离，并立即送往收容机构。
And so Eric Erickson was unsure of what to do so he called his good friend Margaret Mead to ask for her advice. Margaret Mead to ask for her advice. So as the story goes, she agreed with the doctors and advised that Eric and the Erickson family send Neil away. And the mom is under sedation at this point? That's how the story is recounted by his biographer and presumably Joan is not involved in this decision. And Erickson agrees to allow Neil to be sent away.
埃里克·埃里克森不确定该怎么做，于是他打电话给好友玛格丽特·米德寻求建议。玛格丽特·米德寻求建议。故事是这样的，她同意医生的观点，建议埃里克和埃里克森一家把尼尔送走。当时母亲还在镇静状态下吗？这是他的传记作者讲述的故事，据推测琼没有参与这个决定。埃里克森同意将尼尔送走。
And then he went home and told his other children that Neil had died during childbirth. Wow. When I first heard this story, it was, I was shocked. Not because this happened. I was aware that children with Down syndrome were stigmatized and were excluded, and especially in that time period. But I was amazed to learn that Margaret Mead,
然后他回到家，告诉其他孩子尼尔在分娩时夭折了。天哪。当我第一次听到这个故事时，我感到震惊。不是因为这件事发生了。我知道唐氏综合征儿童在那个时期受到污名化和排斥。但我很惊讶地发现玛格丽特·米德，
this eminent, iconic figure who is the sort of symbol of tolerance and acceptance of cultural diversity, that she had played a role in this banishment of Neil, as you say, the puzzling thing is that she is pushing back against the idea that there are inherent biological traits and characteristics that culturally is dominant. Why would she then say that this infant needs to be sent away? It doesn't seem to make sense. Right. It doesn't. Yeah. And I'm not sure we'll ever know exactly what Margaret Mead was thinking. We can only speculate, right, as to what were the rationales in that time frame. And yeah, there was a number of different ideas circulating. The very term Mongolism was this sort of diagnosis, right? But it kind of marked people, babies with this condition as somehow like so radically other, right? That it was a sort of dehumanizing type of diagnosis and
这位杰出的、标志性的人物，作为宽容和接受文化多样性的象征，竟然在尼尔被放逐的过程中扮演了角色。正如你所说，令人困惑的是，她一直在反驳那种认为存在内在生物学特征和特性的观点，而这种观点在文化上是主流。为什么她会说这个婴儿需要被送走？这似乎说不通。没错。确实说不通。是的。我不确定我们是否能确切知道玛格丽特·米德当时在想什么。我们只能推测，在那个时间框架内，背后的理由是什么。是的，当时流传着许多不同的观点。“蒙古症”这个词本身就是一种诊断，对吧？但它给患有这种疾病的婴儿打上了某种“彻底异类”的标签，这是一种非人化的诊断和
rhetoric. And then there's this also at the time there is this expectation that children with disabilities are just this tremendous burden that, you know, they can't possibly have a good or satisfactory life and that it will just create tremendous hardship for the family and for the mother in particular. And the trauma of having to raise a child with a disability will just be overwhelming. It'll be too damaging for the other kids. And so this is just better for everyone. So there's these kinds of attitudes, right,
修辞。当时还有一种预期，即残疾儿童是一个巨大的负担，他们不可能拥有美好或令人满意的生活，这只会给家庭，特别是给母亲带来巨大的困难。抚养残疾儿童的创伤将是压倒性的。这对其他孩子来说太具破坏性了。所以这对每个人都好。所以当时存在这些态度，对吧，
that are dominant at that time period. And presumably this is something that influenced the advice that Meade had given to Erickson. The doctors who advised Eric Erickson to send his newborn son away believe the baby was deficient. Today, we might say the baby had a disability. A more radical view might argue that baby Neil was simply different. When we come back, Tom Pearson lives out the troubled debates of his field in his own life.
这些态度在那个时期占据主导地位。据推测，这影响了米德给埃里克森的建议。那些建议埃里克·埃里克森送走刚出生儿子的医生认为这个婴儿有缺陷。今天，我们可能会说这个婴儿有残疾。一种更激进的观点可能会认为，小尼尔只是与众不同。稍后回来，汤姆·皮尔逊将在他自己的生活中重演他所在领域那些令人不安的辩论。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. On a cold February morning in 2015, anthropologist Tom Pearson's partner Tiffany gave birth to their second child, Michaela. Tom remembers it as a magical time. We were at the birthing clinic at the hospital, and Tiffany labored there for several hours. And I recall walking through the hospital and accompanying her and supporting her and doing all those things that an expectant father does. And then Tiffany gave birth to Michaela, and Michaela was placed immediately on top of Tiffany's chest so that they could bond. And it was a beautiful, beautiful sight. And just to kind of lean in next to Tiffany and just see her just stroking Michaela's brow.
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2015年一个寒冷的二月早晨，人类学家汤姆·皮尔逊的伴侣蒂芙尼生下了他们的第二个孩子米凯拉。汤姆记得那是一段神奇的时光。我们在医院的生育诊所，蒂芙尼在那里分娩了几个小时。我记得在医院里走来走去，陪伴她、支持她，做着准爸爸该做的一切。然后蒂芙尼生下了米凯拉，米凯拉被立即放在蒂芙尼的胸口，以便她们建立亲密关系。那是一个美丽、美丽的景象。我凑近蒂芙尼，看着她抚摸着米凯拉的额头。
And it was amazing an amazing experience. It's kind of blurry now, the immediate moments after the birth, but I recall holding Michaela, it was one of the first times, and feeling as if she felt a little light. That was the only thing that came to mind, even though she was, by newborn standards, not undersized at all.
那是一次奇妙的经历。出生后的最初时刻现在有点模糊了，但我记得抱着米凯拉，那是第一次，感觉她好像有点轻。这是我脑海中浮现的唯一念头，尽管按照新生儿的标准，她一点也不瘦小。
But you know, just kind of a little light, a little, almost a little floppy. But nothing like too exceptional. In the first days after Tom and Tiffany returned home, they adjusted to life with their toddler, Adric, and now baby Michaela. Slowly, they noticed small details about Michaela that differed from Adric. For example, nurses at the hospital had taken prints of Michaela's baby feet. When Tom looked at them, he wondered, is that normal? So when we did the footprint, you know, there's this wide space between Michaela's big toe and The one next to it and I noticed that and thought hmm interesting
但你知道，就是感觉有点轻，有点软绵绵的。但没什么特别异常的。汤姆和蒂芙尼回到家后的最初几天，他们适应了与蹒跚学步的儿子阿德里克以及刚出生的米凯拉一起的生活。慢慢地，他们注意到米凯拉身上一些与阿德里克不同的小细节。例如，医院的护士给米凯拉的脚印留了底。当汤姆看着它们时，他心想，这正常吗？所以当我们做脚印时，你知道，米凯拉的大脚趾和旁边的脚趾之间有很大的空隙，我注意到了这一点，心想，嗯，有趣。
And I remember critically dismissing that but then also noticing yeah like something a little different about Michaela's Features right and I began to dwell on her ears. Her ears were a little smaller than Adrix had been. And I asked Tiffany, you know, did the pediatrician say anything when she evaluated Michaela? She said, no, she said she's perfectly healthy. So it's like, you know, okay, it's nothing, right? I'm just, these are just, I'm worrying again.
我记得当时批判性地否定了这个想法，但随后又注意到，是的，米凯拉的特征确实有点不同。我开始纠结于她的耳朵。她的耳朵比阿德里克当时的小。我问蒂芙尼，儿科医生评估米凯拉时说了什么吗？她说，没有，她说她非常健康。所以我想，好吧，没什么，对吧？我只是……我只是又在担心了。
My anxiety is over, overacting, and I'm dwelling on things that I'm worrying again. My anxiety is over overacting and I'm dwelling on things that I'm making up. And it was only after being home, maybe a day or two after Michaela was born at that point, that like the nagging doubts continued. You know, something just seemed a little bit off. What did you do, Tom? off. What did you do, Tom? I did what probably most people in American society do today. They start searching things on the internet, right?
我的焦虑反应过度了，我在纠结一些我编造出来的事情。在米凯拉出生后回家一两天，那种挥之不去的疑虑依然存在。你知道，有些事情看起来确实有点不对劲。你做了什么，汤姆？你做了什么，汤姆？我做了今天美国社会大多数人可能会做的事。他们开始在网上搜索，对吧？
And I just typed in Down syndrome. Among the top of the list were these not only descriptions, but images of infants with Down syndrome. And I thought, holy, wow, like that kind of looks like Michaela and it was just like this stunning moment of realization that Michaela might have Down syndrome. And so I thought I need to tell Tiffany. I reluctantly walked upstairs. And at that point we were, you know, living in this hundred year old house.
我输入了“唐氏综合征”。列表最前面不仅有描述，还有唐氏综合征婴儿的图片。我想，天哪，这看起来有点像米凯拉。那一刻我意识到米凯拉可能患有唐氏综合征，这真是令人震惊。我想我得告诉蒂芙尼。我不情愿地走上楼。当时我们住在这栋有一百年历史的房子里。
So these beautiful wood stairs that are just sort of like groaning as I walked up the stairs and even stopped halfway up to look out the window and just kind of ponder like, okay, how am I going to bring this up with her? But I got to do this. And so I carry my iPad up the next set of stairs and walk into the room and encounter Tiffany sitting on the bed, nursing Michaela. She's got her computer in her lap and she has tears in her eyes. And so I just, I walked over and looked at her screen
那些漂亮的木楼梯在我走上去时吱吱作响，我甚至在半路停下来看向窗外，思考着：好吧，我该怎么跟她提起这件事？但我必须这么做。于是我带着iPad走上剩下的楼梯，走进房间，看到蒂芙尼坐在床上给米凯拉喂奶。她的电脑放在膝盖上，眼里含着泪水。我走过去看了看她的屏幕，
and she had also searched Down syndrome almost simultaneously when I was doing it. The next day, the two parents brought their baby daughter to see a pediatrician to conduct some tests. Tests that would determine if Michaela had Down syndrome. So we had to go for a blood draw and then they had to send the blood sample to a lab. You know, they said it could take up to a week
她几乎和我同时搜索了“唐氏综合征”。第二天，这对父母带着女儿去看儿科医生进行了一些检查。这些检查将确定米凯拉是否患有唐氏综合征。我们必须去抽血，然后他们必须把血样送到实验室。他们说可能需要一周时间，
and I think it was from like Monday to Friday, if I recall. And what was that like waiting for those five days Tom? Yeah, it was extraordinarily stressful and transformative and dislocating psychologically. The pediatrician had, you know, she had said, you know, if I was a betting person, I would bet against Down syndrome. But we went home and I sort of descended into this sort of descended into this sense of tragedy or grieving. I had no experience with Down syndrome, knew very little about it.
我记得是从周一到周五。等待那五天是什么感觉，汤姆？是的，那是非常令人痛苦、具有变革性且在心理上让人错乱的经历。儿科医生曾说，如果我是个赌徒，我会赌她没有唐氏综合征。但我们回家后，我陷入了一种悲剧感或哀伤感。我对唐氏综合征没有任何经验，知之甚少。
And I just had this fear that I don't want this, right? I don't want a child that is quote unquote abnormal. I thought, God, I wish she doesn't have Down syndrome. I hope she doesn't have Down syndrome. I hope she doesn't. And it was a sense of something tragic was happening. I'm wondering at this point, did you spend some time reading up about Down syndrome, what it was, and what the effects would be? That would have been a logical thing to do and a proactive and healthy thing to do, but I didn't. I experienced a sense of dread and tried to distance myself from Michaela and was
我当时有一种恐惧，我不想要这个，对吧？我不想要一个所谓的“不正常”的孩子。我想，上帝，我希望她没有唐氏综合征。我希望她没有。这是一种悲剧正在发生的感觉。我想知道，当时你有没有花时间阅读关于唐氏综合征的信息，它是什么，以及会有什么影响？那本来是合乎逻辑、积极且健康的做法，但我没有。我感到一种恐惧，并试图与米凯拉保持距离，
just hoping and longing that she wouldn't have Down syndrome. And even found myself pondering Down syndrome. And even found myself pondering maybe if she didn't survive these first days that would just spare us from having to deal with this. So there was this sort of like indirect so-called death wish, right? I mean, it's not like a conscious over thing, but like, yeah, like I didn't want her to survive, right? Just to spare us from having to deal with this trauma, this tragedy. I think that really illustrated just the depth of uncertainty and the sense of like dislocation I was was experiencing in that moment.
只是希望和渴望她没有唐氏综合征。我甚至发现自己在想，如果她没能挺过最初的几天，那就能让我们免于面对这一切。所以有一种间接的所谓“死亡愿望”，对吧？我的意思是，这不是一种有意识的念头，但确实，我不希望她活下来，只是为了让我们免于面对这种创伤和悲剧。我认为这真正说明了我在那一刻所经历的不确定性和错乱感的深度。
After several long days the pediatrician called Tom, Tiffany, and Michaela into our office to review the test results. And then she just looked at us and said I'm sorry. That was a delivery of the diagnosis. And I just experienced this rush of grief as if someone had just died. Like that was the feeling that came over me. Tom suddenly felt like he needed air. How could this be happening to him?
几天后，儿科医生把汤姆、蒂芙尼和米凯拉叫到办公室查看检查结果。她看着我们说：“我很抱歉。”这就是诊断结果的传达。我感到一阵悲伤涌上心头，就像有人刚刚去世一样。这就是我当时的感觉。汤姆突然觉得需要呼吸新鲜空气。这怎么会发生在他身上？
Why was this happening to him? So while we were still at the doctor's office, Tiffany was waiting for something with Michaela. And I said, I need to go for a walk. And so I went for a walk around the building. And then I went back to my car and was sitting there with a door open. And it's a sunny day in March in Wisconsin.
为什么这会发生在他身上？所以当我们还在医生办公室时，蒂芙尼正带着米凯拉等什么东西。我说：“我需要出去走走。”于是我在大楼周围走了一圈。然后我回到车里，开着车门坐着。那是威斯康星州三月一个阳光明媚的日子。
There's still snow on the ground, but the warmth of the sun. And I remember sitting there and just feeling this like impulse, like just turn on the car and just go, just drive, just leave. Tom did not drive away. He and Tiffany and Michaela left together. We started driving together to nowhere in particular, but just to go for a drive and to talk and to process. And yeah, just wondering like, what does this mean? Like, will Michaela ever ride a bike?
地上还有积雪，但阳光很温暖。我记得坐在那里，心里产生了一种冲动：发动汽车，直接走，直接开车离开。汤姆没有开车离开。他和蒂芙尼、米凯拉一起离开了。我们开始开车，没有特定的目的地，只是为了兜风、交谈和消化这一切。是的，只是在想，这意味着什么？米凯拉以后能骑自行车吗？
That was one of the first things that I thought about. Will she get married? You know, is she gonna live on her own? Like, so all these things that we take for granted, right, as these kind of benchmarks of growing up and achieving something, like we were beginning to like, ponder like, what does this mean for Michaela? All of us look for sources of comfort and insight
这是我最初想到的事情之一。她会结婚吗？她能独立生活吗？所以我们认为理所当然的那些成长和成就的基准，我们开始思考，这对米凯拉意味着什么？我们所有人都在经历困难时期时，
when we go through hard times. For Tom, that came from family, from Tiffany, from his brother with whom he had always been close, but it also came from his field of study. He decided to start learning about Down syndrome through the perspective of anthropology. The first tool of the anthropologist is observation, to notice the unusual,
寻找安慰和洞察力的来源。对汤姆来说，这来自家庭，来自蒂芙尼，来自他一直关系亲密的兄弟，但也来自他的研究领域。他决定从人类学的角度开始了解唐氏综合征。人类学家的第一个工具是观察，去注意不寻常的事物，
but to also see everyday things with curiosity and freshness. Tom started by observing himself. How had he responded to Michaela's diagnosis? Why had he responded that way? I had experienced grief and some people around me had said they were sorry, right? They had offered condolences, but that didn't fit. I mean, our child didn't die. And I immediately began to try to detach myself. And then also, I think there's a sort of dehumanizing of my own child in that case, right? And one of the things that I began to then think about
但也以好奇和新鲜的眼光看待日常事物。汤姆从观察自己开始。他是如何应对米凯拉的诊断的？为什么他会有那样的反应？我经历了悲伤，周围有些人说他们很抱歉，他们表示了哀悼，但这并不合适。我的意思是，我们的孩子并没有去世。我立即开始试图让自己抽离。而且，我认为在那种情况下，我自己对孩子有一种非人化的倾向。在我开始思考之后，
after Michaela came into our lives and as we're settling into just the routines of parenting two kids and a child with Down syndrome and coming to terms with that is then wanting to understand like why is it that I sort of marked her as so radically different as to experience that deep sense of rejection and what's going on in the culture around me that would inform that experience and what has gone on historically, right, that has shaped how we think about and encounter and experience Down syndrome in the present.
在米凯拉进入我们的生活，我们开始适应抚养两个孩子（其中一个患有唐氏综合征）的日常琐事并接受这一切之后，我开始想要理解：为什么我把她标记为如此彻底的“异类”，以至于经历了那种深刻的拒绝感？我周围的文化中发生了什么导致了这种体验？历史上发生了什么塑造了我们今天思考、接触和经历唐氏综合征的方式？
Tom realized that one component of his reaction was psychological. His grief was not about Michaela. It was a grief about his own failed expectations. So all the assumptions that I had had about having a child and having a quote unquote perfect child and a certain type of family and what does it mean to grow up and what does it mean to achieve something and be successful? That was all being scrambled.
汤姆意识到他反应的一个组成部分是心理上的。他的悲伤不是关于米凯拉的。这是关于他自己破灭的期望的悲伤。所以，关于拥有一个孩子、拥有一个所谓的“完美”孩子、拥有某种家庭、成长意味着什么、取得成就和成功意味着什么的所有假设，都被打乱了。
That was all being unsettled. And this previously imagined future that is shaped by all these taken for granted beliefs and cultural ideas about what it means to do these things and have a good life, that had all been unmoored and unsettled. And so that sense of loss, right, I've come to see as mourning the loss of this imagined future. In addition to that, then wanting to understand like, why is it that I experienced a diagnosis in this way? Tom noticed that what he was wrestling with was not merely psychological. It involved a long history. He was confronting the same questions that had divided anthropologists in the 19th
这一切都变得动荡不安。这个曾经被所有理所当然的信念和文化观念所塑造的想象中的未来，关于做这些事和过上好生活意味着什么，这一切都失去了根基。所以那种失落感，我开始将其视为对失去这个想象中未来的哀悼。除此之外，我还想理解，为什么我会以这种方式经历诊断？汤姆注意到他所纠结的不仅仅是心理问题。它涉及一段漫长的历史。他正在面对那些在19世纪
and 20th centuries. Was a baby like Michaela deficient or just different? My own assumptions were shaped by the existing prejudices and bias that circulates in our society that is so deeply embedded that we don't even recognize it, right? This assumption about what is normal or abnormal, what is desirable or undesirable, how that shapes and informs our hopes and dreams for ourselves and for our children and even someone like trained in a field like anthropology, I still found myself in retrospect, right, influenced by these type of prejudices and expectations. During his research, Tom came across the story
和20世纪分裂了人类学家的相同问题。像米凯拉这样的婴儿是有缺陷的，还是仅仅与众不同？我自己的假设受到社会中流传的现有偏见的影响，这些偏见根深蒂固，以至于我们甚至没有意识到。这种关于什么是正常或异常、什么是可取或不可取的假设，如何塑造和影响我们对自己和孩子的希望与梦想。即使是像我这样受过人类学训练的人，回顾过去，我仍然发现自己受到了这些偏见和期望的影响。在研究过程中，汤姆偶然发现了
of how Margaret Mead recommended to Eric Erickson that he reject his son because the baby had Down syndrome. One aspect of the affair that struck Tom immediately, the terms for the condition itself, Mongolism and Mongolian idiocy spoke volumes. I asked him to explain what he'd found. Yeah, that's a fascinating history. The series of features or characteristics that we often associate with Down syndrome things like the shape of the eye perhaps or neck shape shorter stature
玛格丽特·米德建议埃里克·埃里克森抛弃他儿子的故事，因为那个婴儿患有唐氏综合征。这件事中让汤姆立即感到震惊的一个方面是，该病症本身的术语——“蒙古症”和“蒙古痴呆症”——说明了一切。我请他解释他发现了什么。是的，那是一段引人入胜的历史。我们通常与唐氏综合征联系在一起的一系列特征，比如眼睛的形状、颈部形状、身材矮小，
You know, there are certain characteristics that we tend to visibly associate with Down syndrome Today we know that Down syndrome is a chromosomal condition and there is a an extra copy of the is a chromosomal condition and there is an extra copy of the 21st chromosome. And it's associated with certain characteristics, right, that many people can visibly probably recognize. And these characteristics were first described by John Langdon Downe in the 19th century. He was a supervisor of an institution where people with disabilities were sent. Being a supervisor of an institution where people with disabilities were sent. Being a supervisor of this institution, he described this pattern and he didn't know how to make sense of it. And so he kind of viewed it through a racialized lens stemming from the sort
你知道，有一些特征是我们倾向于在视觉上与唐氏综合征联系在一起的。今天我们知道唐氏综合征是一种染色体疾病，多出了一条21号染色体。它与某些特征相关联，许多人可能在视觉上就能认出来。这些特征最早由约翰·朗顿·唐在19世纪描述。他是残疾人收容机构的负责人。作为这个机构的负责人，他描述了这种模式，但他不知道如何解释它。于是他通过一种种族化的视角来看待它，源于某种
of so-called Asian eyes. And he compared these features to features in the 19th century were associated with the so-called Mongol race. And so he speculated that these residents of his institution, who were born to white European families, but how can they have these so-called Mongolian characteristics, that it must be some sort of like reversion to this prior or more primitive evolutionary state that occurred in the womb. Wow. So he's kind of viewing this,
所谓的“亚洲眼”。他将这些特征与19世纪与所谓的“蒙古人种”相关的特征进行了比较。因此他推测，这些出生在白人欧洲家庭的机构居民，怎么会有这些所谓的“蒙古特征”呢？这一定是某种在子宫内发生的、向这种更原始的进化状态的倒退。天哪。所以他是在用
interpreting it through the lens of ideas about human evolution, these flawed problematic notions of race, as well as viewing it as something that's rigid and innate. So that's where the term Mongolism then comes from. This is, you know, in the 1860s, 1870s, so then into well into the 1940s, people are still using this terminology that is heavily racialized. I mean, I hadn't really understood or realized the medical understanding of Down syndrome, how it intersected with racial classifications. It really is, it's sort of striking how far back that goes.
人类进化的视角、这些有缺陷且成问题的种族观念来解读它，并将其视为某种僵化和先天的东西。这就是“蒙古症”这个词的由来。这是在19世纪60年代、70年代，一直到20世纪40年代，人们仍在使用这种带有强烈种族色彩的术语。我的意思是，我之前并没有真正理解或意识到唐氏综合征的医学理解是如何与种族分类交叉的。这确实令人震惊，它追溯得如此久远。
One of the other things you talk about is this idea of what's called the Simeon crease. What is the Simeon crease? Describe that for me, Tom. What was the thinking there? Yeah. I first encountered this term in the doctor's office prior to when Michaela was diagnosed, but when we were getting the blood test to count her chromosomes to determine whether or not she had Down syndrome. So the pediatrician made a comment about Michaela not having a simian crease on her palm. And I looked down at my palm and I had no idea what that meant.
你谈到的另一件事是所谓的“通贯掌”。什么是通贯掌？汤姆，请为我描述一下。当时的思路是什么？是的。我是在米凯拉被诊断之前，在医生办公室进行血液检查以计算染色体以确定她是否患有唐氏综合征时，第一次接触到这个术语的。儿科医生评论说米凯拉的手掌没有通贯掌。我低头看了看自己的手掌，根本不知道那是什么意思。
So yeah, I would later learn that this refers to some people with Down syndrome have a noticeable single crease on their palm. The term simian, right, is a reference to non-human primates and In the early 20th century in the context of the eugenics movement there is speculation about how do we interpret Mongolism and does this condition represent this sort of like or primitive evolutionary state and and yeah that notion of sim-increase and reinforce this association
后来我才知道，这指的是一些唐氏综合征患者手掌上有一条明显的单条折痕。“通贯掌”这个词是对非人灵长类动物的引用。在20世纪初的优生学运动背景下，人们猜测如何解读“蒙古症”，这种疾病是否代表了某种原始的进化状态。是的，关于通贯掌的概念强化了这种关联，
of Down syndrome of what was then called mongolism with something that is less than human. So you're reading about these things, you're reading about the history of anthropology, the history of Down syndrome. You also are the parent of a child with Down syndrome now. And I'm wondering, are you seeing things in your child's life that reflect this deep history of how we have thought about the disorder? Yeah, there's a long history, not only of sort of devaluing
将唐氏综合征（当时称为蒙古症）与某种“非人”的东西联系起来。所以你正在阅读这些内容，阅读人类学的历史、唐氏综合征的历史。你现在也是一个唐氏综合征孩子的父亲。我想知道，你在孩子的生活中是否看到了反映这种关于该疾病的深刻历史观的东西？是的，不仅有通过“蒙古症”等术语贬低和非人化唐氏综合征患者的历史，
and dehumanizing people with Down syndrome through terminology such as Mongolism, but also through that impulse to institutionalize, right? And institutions that would house children with disabilities or other conditions or people with mental illness like have a long and troubled history. But these reflect that the history of wanting to create like this division between, you know, normal and abnormal, right? And yeah, a lot has changed, right? I mean this emergence of a disability rights movement, you know, the Americans with Disabilities Act has, you know, the Americans with disabilities act has, you know, enabled a world in which people like Michaela are included in ways that previous generations weren't.
还有那种想要将他们收容起来的冲动。那些收容残疾儿童或其他疾病患者或精神病患者的机构，有着漫长而令人不安的历史。但这些反映了那种想要在“正常”和“异常”之间制造鸿沟的历史。当然，很多事情已经改变了，残疾人权利运动的兴起，《美国残疾人法案》创造了一个像米凯拉这样的人能够以以前几代人无法想象的方式被包容的世界。
Even though I like grapple with those uncertainties and that sense of rejection before we knew, you know, Michaela definitively had Down syndrome and there was a sort of period of coming to terms with it, there was never a doubt that we were going to bring her home and care for her. But at the same time, right, like there is still, I think, a lot of ways in which this history of dehumanizing and devaluing people with Down syndrome, people with disabilities, that continues to inform how we experience and perceive disability in the present. And just, you know, my own own experience when Michaela was diagnosed,
尽管我在知道米凯拉确诊前曾纠结于那些不确定性和拒绝感，也经历过一段接受的过程，但我们从未怀疑过要带她回家并照顾她。但与此同时，我认为这种非人化和贬低唐氏综合征患者、残疾人的历史，仍然在影响着我们今天如何体验和感知残疾。就像我自己的经历，当米凯拉被诊断出时，
and this is sort of like reaction of some people expressing condolences, right? Saying they're sorry, as if something tragic had happened, references to a semi-increase, right? Like there's a baggage with that term, there's a legacy to that. The ways in which this subtly marks someone as different, as outside what is considered normal or desirable.
有些人表达哀悼的反应，说他们很抱歉，好像发生了什么悲剧一样，还有对通贯掌的提及，这些术语背后都有沉重的包袱和遗产。这些方式微妙地将某人标记为“不同”，标记为被认为正常或可取范围之外的人。
And there's a subtle sort of devaluing that occurs. So one of the things that you are fascinated by, and I think is a fascinating question is when is something a difference and when is something a disability? And I think we've been circling around this question for a bit now of trying to understand are disabilities just differences?
这产生了一种微妙的贬低。所以你着迷的一件事，我认为是一个引人入胜的问题，就是什么时候是“差异”，什么时候是“残疾”？我想我们一直在围绕这个问题讨论，试图理解残疾仅仅是差异吗？
Are differences disabilities? And of course, perhaps these are just words, but the words have meaning and they have power because differences are things that we accept that we say, well, people are have power because differences are things that we accept, that we say, well, people are different. Disabilities are things that we should confront, things that we should treat. Have you thought about whether you think of Down syndrome
差异是残疾吗？当然，也许这些只是词汇，但词汇有意义，也有力量，因为差异是我们接受的东西，我们说，好吧，人们是不同的。残疾是我们应该面对、应该治疗的东西。你有没有想过你是否认为唐氏综合征
as being difference or disability? Yeah, definitely. I am not someone who identifies as a person with a disability, but I now am the parent of a child who is disabled. What does that mean? You know, she physically has no health impairments or issues, she engages with language differently,
是差异还是残疾？是的，当然。我不是一个自认为是残疾人的人，但我现在是一个残疾孩子的父亲。那意味着什么？你知道，她在生理上没有健康障碍或问题，她与语言的互动方式不同，
and she learns differently, and she does not learn as quickly as her peers do, and that's obvious, right? And so to what extent are these impairments or are they differences, right? And it depends on the context. The social conditions that we inhabit are what shape whether or not we are included
她学习的方式也不同，她学习的速度不如同龄人快，这是显而易见的。那么这些在多大程度上是障碍，或者它们只是差异？这取决于语境。我们所处的社会条件决定了我们是否被包容、
or accommodated or experience impairment. Many of the barriers and limitations that people with disabilities or health impairments encounter are created by society. They're created by the lack of resources, by the stigma, by the prejudice that continues to exist, by the lack of accommodations, right? So there are social origins to the impairments that people experience. I think it's important to recognize that something like Down syndrome,
被接纳，或者经历障碍。残疾人或健康受损者遇到的许多障碍和限制是由社会造成的。它们是由资源匮乏、污名化、持续存在的偏见、缺乏便利设施造成的。所以人们经历的障碍有社会根源。我认为重要的是要认识到，像唐氏综合征这样
which is a chromosomal condition, but it's also part of the human experience. This is not caused specifically by anything. There's not an environmental cause to it. It just happens and it has always happened and it happens across the world, right? So this is part of the human story. It's part of the fabric of human diversity. At the same time, right, we can't just reduce it down to another form of difference. In today's world, even though so much has changed, to parent a child with disability,
一种染色体疾病，也是人类体验的一部分。这不是由任何特定原因引起的。它没有环境诱因。它只是发生了，而且一直都在发生，在世界各地都在发生。所以这是人类故事的一部分。它是人类多样性结构的一部分。与此同时，我们不能仅仅把它简化为另一种形式的差异。在当今世界，尽管发生了这么多变化，作为残疾孩子的父母，
to parent a child with Down syndrome, it's also find yourself as an advocate, as an activist in ways that you never imagined or intended, because you're now navigating a world where you are encountering often unexpectedly barriers and perceptions and prejudices that still need to be overcome. Hmm, hmm. You know, and I suppose some people might say,
作为唐氏综合征孩子的父母，你也会发现自己成为了一个你从未想象或打算成为的倡导者和活动家，因为你现在正在一个世界中航行，经常会意外地遇到仍然需要克服的障碍、观念和偏见。嗯，嗯。你知道，我想有些人可能会说，
look, there really are these things that are disabilities. And I'd actually want to press you on this question, but as you were talking just now, I was just reflecting, you know, I'm very short-sighted. And if I were to lose my glasses or if the technology to make glasses didn't exist, I probably would consider myself to be disabled at that point. I really wouldn't be able to function. I'd barely be able to make it down the stairs, let alone get out on the street and drive around. But the fact that the technology to make contact lenses and glasses is so ubiquitous, and I
看，确实存在残疾这种事情。我其实很想就这个问题追问你，但刚才你说话的时候，我一直在反思，你知道，我近视很深。如果我弄丢了眼镜，或者制造眼镜的技术不存在，在那一刻，我可能会认为自己是残疾人。我真的无法正常生活。我连下楼都费劲，更别提走到街上开车了。但事实是，制造隐形眼镜和框架眼镜的技术太普及了，而我
wake up in the morning and I put on my glasses, and then I don't think about the fact that I'm short-sighted, and nobody else thinks about it at all, because there's a perfect solution for the short-sightedness. And suddenly the thing that used to be seen as a disability is now seen as a minor annoyance, nothing more than that. And in some ways, it to me sort of reflects this idea that things that we think of as being disabilities in some ways are always a construction between the physical experience of the disability and the social world that lives around that disability. Yeah. And there are all sorts of ways
早上醒来戴上眼镜，我就不会去想自己近视的事，别人也完全不会在意，因为近视有一个完美的解决方案。突然之间，曾经被视为残疾的东西现在被视为一种小麻烦，仅此而已。在某种程度上，这对我来说反映了这样一个观点：我们认为的残疾在某种程度上总是残疾的生理体验与围绕该残疾的社会世界之间的一种建构。是的。而且有各种各样的方式
in which we accommodate impairments, right? We come up with ways to deal with that and life goes on. And if we live long enough, we're gonna age and our bodies are gonna change and we're gonna have fewer abilities than we did as young people. I mean, these are inherent truisms, right? Of the human experience.
来适应损伤，对吧？我们想出应对的方法，生活还要继续。如果我们活得够久，我们就会变老，身体会发生变化，我们的能力会比年轻时少。我的意思是，这些是人类经验中固有的真理，对吧？
So on some level disability is inherent to what it means to be human. And we can we can deal with it, we can accommodate it, we can make the best of it. The question comes into play of like why do certain ways of being and living get devalued, right, and marginalized and viewed as not worth living or become the subject or target of so much stigma and prejudice that that in itself becomes a further disablement for people having to deal with that, you know, that bias.
所以在某种层面上，残疾是人类本质的一部分。我们可以应对它，可以适应它，可以充分利用它。问题在于，为什么某些生存和生活方式会被贬低、边缘化，被视为不值得活下去，或者成为如此多污名和偏见的客体或目标，以至于这本身就成了人们不得不应对那种偏见而遭受的进一步残疾。
with that, you know, that bias. Despite what she recommended to Eric Erickson, Margaret Mead's work changed the way we think about differences and disabilities. Differences did not automatically imply deficiencies. Over time, and as the culture changed around her, Margaret Mead began to advocate for greater disability rights. She came to critique the kinds of institutions to which she damned Neil Erickson. For the kind of society that will value each individual, save more blind people and more deaf people.
那种偏见。尽管玛格丽特·米德向埃里克·埃里克森提出了建议，但她的工作改变了我们对差异和残疾的看法。差异并不自动意味着缺陷。随着时间的推移，随着她周围文化的改变，玛格丽特·米德开始倡导更大的残疾人权利。她开始批判她曾把尼尔·埃里克森送进去的那种机构。为了那种能够重视每个个体、拯救更多盲人和聋人的社会。
And probably when we do this, we will also be saving kinds of genius that we've never been able to save before. It's perfectly possible that you have various sorts of linkages, genetic linkages, that mean that certain kinds of great skills, great imaginative abilities, have perished right through the generations because we weren't able to save a certain kind of person. So I think we are going to have to widen the range of the people whom we treat as human and whom we build our society so they can live in it, so the deaf can live in it and the blind can live in it and people with special disabilities.
当我们这样做时，我们可能也会拯救我们以前从未能拯救过的天才。完全有可能存在各种各样的遗传联系，意味着某些伟大的技能、伟大的想象力在几代人中消失了，因为我们没能拯救某种特定的人。所以我认为我们将不得不扩大我们视为人类的范围，并以此构建我们的社会，让他们能够生活在其中，让聋人、盲人和有特殊残疾的人都能生活在其中。
At the same time we may hope to have a greater range of human, greater human variability and therefore greater ability also. After Eric Erickson sent baby Neil away to an institution, his wife Joan reportedly felt devastated by the decision. They rarely discussed Neil. Neil died at age 21 while still living in an institution. Eric and Joan were on vacation in Italy at the time and did not return for the funeral. Instead, according to a memoir by their daughter Sue, they delegated the task to their children, who knew nothing of the sibling they buried. When we come back, Tom wrestles with his new understanding of Down syndrome as he and Tiffany
同时，我们希望拥有更大范围的人类多样性，从而也拥有更大的能力。在埃里克·埃里克森把婴儿尼尔送进机构后，据报道他的妻子琼对这个决定感到崩溃。他们很少谈论尼尔。尼尔在21岁时死于机构中。埃里克和琼当时正在意大利度假，没有回来参加葬礼。相反，根据他们女儿苏的回忆录，他们把任务委托给了他们的孩子们，而孩子们对他们埋葬的兄弟一无所知。当我们回来时，汤姆将重新审视他对唐氏综合症的理解，他和蒂芙尼
debate whether to have a third child. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When his daughter was born diagnosed with Down syndrome, the anthropologist Tom Pearson's own life became a case study of debates that have roiled anthropology for decades. Within weeks of Michaela's birth, Tom and his wife Tiffany encountered a question from friends and family. When are you going to have another child? And it was a little bit strange because when someone has had their second child,
争论是否要第三个孩子。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当他的女儿被诊断出患有唐氏综合症时，人类学家汤姆·皮尔森自己的生活成为了几十年来困扰人类学的辩论的案例研究。在米凯拉出生后的几周内，汤姆和他的妻子蒂芙尼遇到了来自朋友和家人的问题。你们什么时候要下一个孩子？这有点奇怪，因为当某人有了第二个孩子时，
the last thing you expect is people be asking you when you're going to have your next child. And it was almost as if like, because something was quote unquote wrong with Michaela that when are we going to try again to have the right kid? And I remember talking with Tiffany and I just made some comment about, yeah, if, if you were ever to get pregnant again, we would need to have prenatal testing and Tiffany said, why is that?
你最不希望的就是人们问你什么时候要下一个孩子。这几乎就像是，因为米凯拉有什么所谓的“不对劲”，所以我们什么时候再试着生一个“正常的”孩子？我记得和蒂芙尼谈话时，我随口说了一句，是的，如果你再怀孕，我们需要进行产前检查，蒂芙尼问，为什么？
And without even thinking about it, I just said, oh, so we would know whether or not to abort or terminate the pregnancy. And there was this pause. And I looked up and Tiffany had tears in her eyes. And Michaela is sitting in the baby carrier next to her. And Tiffany says, what are you trying to say? That you don't want Michaela? And yeah, I support the right of women to choose whether or not to continue a pregnancy, right? I support abortion rights and reproductive rights, but I had just assumed, right, that like the thing to do
我甚至没多想就说，哦，这样我们就能知道是否要堕胎或终止妊娠。然后是一阵沉默。我抬头一看，蒂芙尼眼里含着泪水。米凯拉正坐在她旁边的婴儿背带里。蒂芙尼说，你想说什么？你是不想要米凯拉吗？是的，我支持女性选择是否继续怀孕的权利，我支持堕胎权和生殖权利，但我当时只是假设，产前检查
was to prenatally test for Down syndrome. And why is that? A couple of years later, Tom and Tiffany did decide to have another child. We faced that question then from doctors, like, aren't you going to get prenatal testing to see if the unborn baby has Down syndrome, has an extra chromosome? And so we talked about it, we pondered it, we met with an obstetrician. if the unborn baby has Down syndrome, has an extra chromosome. And so we talked about it, we pondered it, we met with an obstetrician, like what would this information tell us other than that counting its chromosomes?
是理所当然的。为什么会这样？几年后，汤姆和蒂芙尼确实决定再要一个孩子。我们当时面临医生提出的问题，比如，你们不去进行产前检查看看未出生的婴儿是否有唐氏综合症、是否有额外的染色体吗？所以我们讨论了它，思考了它，我们见了一位产科医生。如果未出生的婴儿有唐氏综合症，有额外的染色体。所以我们讨论了它，思考了它，我们见了一位产科医生，除了数染色体之外，这些信息还能告诉我们什么？
Like, it's not going to help us in terms of like the potential like health of this unborn child. It's just all it is is a chromosome count. We decided, I mean, that we didn't need that information, you know, that there was no reason why we didn't want to continue the pregnancy and terminating a pregnancy just because of something like Down syndrome, that no longer felt ethically justifiable in ways that I assume that it was, you know, just a couple of years prior. And so, yeah, so we declined to have any sort of
这对于这个未出生孩子的潜在健康状况没有任何帮助。它仅仅只是染色体计数。我们决定，我们不需要这些信息，因为没有理由不想继续怀孕，仅仅因为唐氏综合症之类的原因而终止妊娠，这在伦理上不再像我几年前假设的那样合理了。所以，是的，我们拒绝了任何形式的
genetic testing and then our third child Zora, you know, was born, she does not have Down syndrome, but it wasn't something that we feared at that point anymore. Do you still think of Michaela as having Down syndrome? Is that something that even occurs to you anymore? Does it factor into the way you think about her? Yeah, we don't, I mean, it's interesting
基因检测，然后我们的第三个孩子佐拉出生了，她没有唐氏综合症，但这在当时已经不是我们担心的事了。你现在还认为米凯拉患有唐氏综合症吗？这还是你会想到的事情吗？它会影响你对她的看法吗？是的，我们不会，这很有趣，
because when she was first born and we were grappling with the diagnosis, I constantly thought about Down syndrome. It was just constantly on my mind. And then at some point it faded. And it's not the lens through which I interact with Michaela or view her. Of course she has Down syndrome,
因为当她刚出生，我们还在努力应对诊断结果时，我一直在想唐氏综合症。它一直在我脑海里。但后来在某个时刻，它淡化了。这不是我与米凯拉互动或看待她的视角。当然她有唐氏综合症，
but it's not something that I'm consciously thinking about all the time. And I don't view her as a kid with Down syndrome and she's just Michaela and she's our daughter and she's beautiful and mischievous and clever and curious and she is a wonderful sibling and daughter and cousin and friend and cares deeply about everyone around her. You tell a very charming story in the book about your three children on the playground
但我并不是一直有意识地在想这件事。我不把她看作一个患有唐氏综合症的孩子，她就是米凯拉，她是我们的女儿，她美丽、淘气、聪明、好奇，她是一个很棒的姐妹、女儿、表亲和朋友，非常关心周围的每一个人。你在书中讲了一个关于你的三个孩子在操场上非常迷人的故事，
playing with other kids and sort of talking about one another. And it's a wonderful story because it illustrates in some ways the fact that some of the ways in which adults think about disabilities or differences are not quite the way that children think about these things. And in some ways you actually, we are taught and we learn how to think about disabilities in a certain way. Tell me that story, Tom. Yeah, so it was a few years back,
和其他孩子一起玩，谈论彼此。这是一个很棒的故事，因为它在某种程度上说明了成年人看待残疾或差异的方式与孩子们看待这些事情的方式并不完全相同。在某种程度上，我们被教导并学会了以某种方式看待残疾。给我讲讲那个故事，汤姆。好的，那是几年前，
and like I've done many times, I rode my bike to the playground with Adric, Michaela, and Zora, and there were some other children there, and so they all went to play and climb around on the playground equipment. And Adric, the oldest, began to play with and interact with another child about his age. And suddenly he began to not only introduce himself, but talk about his siblings and kind of list features or characteristics.
像我做过很多次的那样，我骑自行车带着阿德里克、米凯拉和佐拉去了操场，那里还有其他孩子，所以他们都去玩耍，在操场设备上爬来爬去。最大的阿德里克开始和另一个和他年龄相仿的孩子玩耍互动。突然，他不仅开始自我介绍，还谈论他的兄弟姐妹，并列举了一些特征或特质。
He said, my name is Adric. My talent is running and jumping. And I have no idea why he decided to list that talent. But you know, they're playing on this playground and that's what they're doing. They're running and jumping and climbing. And then he looks down and he says, that's Zora, my sister. Adric says, her talent is fighting. And that also made me laugh and then I was just wondering like hey what is Adric gonna say about Michaela who's there playing as well and the child that they were playing with had kind of noticed Michaela right because you
他说，我叫阿德里克。我的天赋是跑步和跳跃。我不知道他为什么决定列出那个天赋。但你知道，他们在操场上玩，这就是他们在做的事情。他们在跑步、跳跃和攀爬。然后他低头说，那是佐拉，我的妹妹。阿德里克说，她的天赋是打架。这也让我笑了，然后我只是想，嘿，阿德里克会怎么评价也在那里玩的米凯拉呢？他们一起玩的那个孩子已经注意到了米凯拉，因为你
know at that point I think she's six years old or so talked a little differently you know she definitely keeps up with Adric and Zora on the playground and climbs and does everything that they do. And she rides bike, but it's not as fast, not as high, not as long sort of thing. So I'm watching and observing this. And then Adric is looking at Michaela and he says, that's Michaela.
知道那时我想她大概六岁左右，说话方式有点不同，她绝对能在操场上跟上阿德里克和佐拉，攀爬并做他们做的一切。她也骑自行车，但没那么快，没那么高，没那么久。所以我看着并观察着。然后阿德里克看着米凯拉说，那是米凯拉。
We haven't figured out her talent yet. He says, that's Michaela. We haven't figured out her talent yet. And that was really amazing to me that in addition to other kids, I often wonder how do Michaela's siblings view her because they interact with her all the time and she's just Michaela. And now and then we talk about Down syndrome with them
我们还没发现她的天赋。他说，那是米凯拉。我们还没发现她的天赋。这对我来说真的很神奇，除了其他孩子，我经常想米凯拉的兄弟姐妹是怎么看她的，因为他们一直和她互动，她就是米凯拉。偶尔我们会和他们谈论唐氏综合症，
and we don't want to ignore that she has Down syndrome and that there are things that are a little bit different and we want to equip them with the language and ability to talk about that. And especially as they get older and are in settings at school and other places to be able to navigate life as a sibling of someone with Down syndrome. But that was really telling that, you know, he didn't view her through the lens of deficiency. Even though he's listing these other physical abilities of himself and Zora, he didn't view her through that lens of deficiency or disability or Down syndrome. He just, she's just Michaela and we haven't figured out her talent yet, but we will.
我们不想忽视她患有唐氏综合症，有些事情确实有点不同，我们想让他们具备谈论这件事的语言和能力。特别是在他们长大后，在学校和其他地方，能够以唐氏综合症患者兄弟姐妹的身份去应对生活。但这真的很能说明问题，他并没有通过缺陷的视角来看待她。尽管他列举了自己和佐拉的其他身体能力，但他并没有通过缺陷、残疾或唐氏综合症的视角来看待她。他只是觉得，她就是米凯拉，我们还没发现她的天赋，但我们会发现的。
And that said a lot to me. Tom Pearson is an anthropologist at the University of Wisconsin-Stout. He's the author of An Ordinary Future, Margaret Mead, The Problem of Disability, and A Child Born Different. Tom, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, I really enjoyed this.
这对我来说意义重大。汤姆·皮尔森是威斯康星大学斯托特分校的人类学家。他是《平凡的未来：玛格丽特·米德、残疾问题与一个与众不同的孩子》一书的作者。汤姆，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，我真的很喜欢这次谈话。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. We end today's show with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. It's brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. For as long as she can remember,
《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天以我们姐妹播客《我未被歌颂的英雄》中的一个故事结束节目。它由T-Mobile for Business为您呈现。在她的记忆中，
Leela Hoffa has struggled to express herself in writing. She says in her first years of school, her teachers didn't notice that anything was wrong. That changed when she met her third grade teacher, Valerie Holmgren, who discovered that Leela had a learning disability called dysgraphia. So Leela's teachers and her parents had a meeting to figure out what to do next. This was honestly quite terrifying because I was just a small child and all these people
莉拉·霍法一直难以用文字表达自己。她说在她上学的前几年，老师们并没有注意到有什么不对劲。当她遇到三年级老师瓦莱丽·霍姆格伦时，情况发生了变化，老师发现莉拉有一种叫书写障碍的学习障碍。所以莉拉的老师和父母开了一个会，商量下一步该怎么办。这老实说非常可怕，因为我只是个小孩，所有这些人
were there gathered around me talking about me and it was pretty scary. We were all sitting around a long table and Mrs. Hohmogren pulled out a computer and opened it to Google Docs and said that there was this cool thing that she wanted to show me. So she showed me how to open speech to text and I did not quite understand what this was at first. Then she showed me that you talk to the computer and it writes down what you're saying. This was just an overwhelming moment for me because I realized all of the the stories and the ideas that I had stuck in my head, there was an easy way to get them down onto paper and to be able to share them with the world. And I just threw my head back and said I could write a thousand stories. It was just an
都聚集在我周围谈论我，这很吓人。我们都坐在长桌旁，霍姆格伦夫人拿出一台电脑，打开谷歌文档，说有一个很酷的东西想给我看。于是她向我展示了如何打开语音转文字功能，我起初不太明白这是什么。然后她向我展示了你对着电脑说话，它就会写下你说的话。这对我来说是一个压倒性的时刻，因为我意识到我脑子里卡住的所有故事和想法，有一种简单的方法可以把它们写在纸上，并能够与世界分享。我只是向后仰着头说，我可以写一千个故事。这只是一个
amazing moment and everybody seemed to be thinking, like, yes, this is going to work. Like, we've made a difference. I still use speech to text daily. I use it to send messages. I use it to write essays in class. I use it to type up emails. And I wrote a story called The Girl Who Couldn't Stop Reading, aka me. So thank you for noticing my potential and noticing that there was so much more to me and that it wasn't just the basic struggle that I was having.
令人惊叹的时刻，每个人似乎都在想，是的，这行得通。我们做出了改变。我至今每天都在使用语音转文字。我用它发送信息，用它在课堂上写论文，用它打电子邮件。我还写了一个故事叫《读个不停的女孩》，也就是我。所以谢谢你注意到我的潜力，注意到我身上还有更多东西，而不仅仅是我正在经历的基本挣扎。
Not only did you notice the handwriting and help me get better at that, but you knew that there was so much inside my head that needed to get out. Leila Hoffa lives in Flagstaff, Arizona. Today's My Unsung Hero story was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. You can find more of these stories on the My Unsung Hero podcast or at myunsunghero.org. If you liked today's episode, please consider becoming a supporter of Hidden Brain.
你不仅注意到了我的笔迹并帮助我改进，而且你知道我脑子里有很多东西需要表达出来。莉拉·霍法住在亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫。今天的《我未被歌颂的英雄》故事由T-Mobile for Business为您呈现。你可以在《我未被歌颂的英雄》播客或myunsunghero.org上找到更多此类故事。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请考虑成为《隐藏的大脑》的支持者。
We build episodes like this for you, and they take an extraordinary amount of effort and research and time. If you find our work valuable to you, please do your part to keep it going. Support us by becoming a subscriber to our program at apple.co. slash hiddenbrain, or by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们为你制作这样的节目，它们需要大量的努力、研究和时间。如果你觉得我们的工作对你有价值，请尽你的一份力量让它继续下去。通过在apple.co/hiddenbrain订阅我们的节目，或访问support.hiddenbrain.org来支持我们。再说一遍，是support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，是support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。